Speaker 1: Let's go now from Tim Scott to
Ron DeSantis. Ron DeSantis still has not
successfully received the personality transplant
that is going to help him in any way. I'm going
to play some cringe video for you. It's difficult
to imagine a less charismatic guy. The New York
Times wrote up his Desantis's recent trip to New
Hampshire. DeSantis amps up his retail campaign in
New Hampshire. The Florida governor met with
state lawmakers and made the standard diner
visit to press flesh with voters, showcasing
his more moderate side. He was not showcasing
his most moderate side. He bragged about
banning pronouns, but more importantly.
Look at the lack of charisma. It's hard to think
of a more awkward and less charismatic guy. Here's
the sand, as I'll describe this for people
not watching. DeSantis enters a diner seems
visibly confused as to how to relate to people
and is kind of told where to stand. And it's
I almost started feeling bad for the guy because
it's almost like when an introvert is forced into
social situations. I take a look at this.
Speaker 4: How are you doing? Wow,
look at this guy. How are you guys? And you see
you guys go right over here. Okay. Yeah. A deal.
Speaker 1: Good deal. Good deal. Go. Hey,
guys. How you doing? Oh, stand here. Oh, yes,
absolutely. Biscuits? Yes, Biscuits.
Speaker 4: Wow. Crowded, huh?
Speaker 1: There are people in this establishment
which suggests that business is transacting.
Speaker 4: How are you doing? It
smells really good, I'll tell you that.
Speaker 1: You know, when these LGBTQ smells
we're doing away with that in Florida, we're
just not going to do it because woke goes to die
in Florida. And if anybody tries to slide turkey
bacon in, it is only real bacon. None of that
sexy stuff. Okay. I'll tell you that right now.
Speaker 4: So we'll do it. Okay. How you doing?
What you're doing? I'm Tim. Answer. Okay. How
are you? I'm wonderful. Great to be here.
Speaker 1: I love that. What's your name?
Tim. Okay. And it's such a little thing,
but it's again, he just. Yeah, every. Every
detail. What's your name? Oh, my. My name's
Jonathan. Okay. Wow. What? What a guy.
Speaker 4: Example where you
guys are saying, Hey, dude, how.
Speaker 1: Are you going to run? Stay tuned right.
Speaker 4: There.
Speaker 1: All right. Then he also, during the
same stop, I think or maybe this was a different
diner. It looks like he's in a I don't know where
he is. Same same sort of thing. He bragged about
how they've banned pronouns in Florida.
Speaker 4: We just get a bill in Florida.
We're not allowing the pronouns.
Like you can't force these kids to be
choosing. They want like a second grader to pick.
Speaker 1: Listen. And if you elect me president,
I'm going to go after adverbs and prepositional
phrases. We're going to just end those like you
wouldn't even believe, because these woke
people, they want to put. And by the way,
capitalization on proper nouns, we're
going to get rid of that so fast that
they're going to get the hell out
of Florida. This guy is not ready.
He is not ready. And it's constitutionally he
just appealing to moderate voters is what was
reported by The New York Times. He bragged about
banning pronouns. There is nothing moderate about
that. And by the way, you can say a lot of bad
things about New Hampshire and not the state.
But what I'm saying, there's a lot of right
wing extremism in New Hampshire. Focusing on
pronouns I don't even know is that it's going
to do it with New Hampshire Republicans, to be
totally honest. So the DeSantis campaign that
still hasn't started looking very, very rough.